okay so everyone on the internet is
arguing about iMHO your social media
users or any heated debate over the
internet acronym IMHO it started with
the folks at BuzzFeed who got into a
heated debate over the abbreviation IMHO
and obviously it's my humble opinion
Europeans obviously honest why would you
have to clarify I've never read it as
but you know what today we're gonna get
to the bottom of this I'm gonna talk to
the experts and I'm gonna talk to the
people let's go so we have to find
Lauren because she's the one who wrote
the article that started this entire
debate I gotta ask you about IMHO what
happened yes I mean thank you you're
welcome my friend Morgan said something
and I responded I am a ciao and she goes
I don't know what you're saying and then
as soon as I said in my honest opinion
some I was getting attacked left left
and right my co-workers were like in my
honest opinion do you mean in my humble
opinion that we've had this huge
miscommunication for years I don't know
you at all yeah I'm like take it or
leave it
in my humble opinion you should cut this
joke in my humble opinion makes you
sound like you're a prospector from the
18th quarter the room was divided it was
bloody and like oh this is kind of
interesting like let's put it to the
masses of the Internet see what they
have to say the majority of the people
the popular vote were with honest I'm
not just giving you my opinion I'm
giving you my honest opinion I'm not
gonna say here lie to you those who
think it's humble they just couldn't
really face the fact that they were
losing their argument is that there's
the phrase in my humble opinion which I
know but nobody says that really anymore
there was a clear winner and it was
honest Lauren's obviously team honest
but we're gonna get a second opinion I
talked to the Busbee news copy chief and
she said in my humble opinion is that a
hundred percent on that or I would say
it's a hundred percent
it's humble that's the answer I was
right from the beginning most of the
dictionary looked at our house
dictionaries merriam-webster and they're
on team humble on Usenet which is
basically like Reddit before there was
read it came out of a longer acronym in
my not so humble opinion and it was used
pretty sarcastically so the general
consensus there was humble there are
many more instances of in my humble
opinion than in my honest opinion we did
the question most people said honest
what that's indicative of is sort of a
generational divide older people are
saying humble and younger people are
saying honest so is it possible that the
younger people could win just because
old people will die before them yes the
one thing we can all agree on is that
the English language is like a goddamn
mess okay Eric what did the people say
the people said first of all I just want
to say that people don't know anything
and they're not smart so going to the
NYU campus because I feel like the kids
there probably have the answer they're
educated they take English classes okay
they're people but they're not they
haven't studied language most people and
why you said that it was honest what
does IMHO mean my ass why honest because
like I always think you're being humble
if it's just in your opinion no but I
always think you're being honest if
you're giving an opinion you're gonna be
honest no I've given opinions that I
have not believed in devil's advocate
whatever
honestly why I don't think our
generation uses the word humble anymore
unless it's talking about like Kendrick
sung wait sit down be humble and
humble or honest is it in my honest
opinion or humble opinion humble are
honest we got it here today it means in
my honest opinion I don't understand why
everybody thinks it's honest it flows
better off the tongue in my honest
opinion or in my humble opinion I would
much rather hear honest opinion but when
I asked the older generation who's wiser
smarter they said humble in my humble
opinion finally why to my dad I said
humble these two right here have said
there's no debate it's a hundred percent
humble we're old school man thank you
for solving the problem thank you guys
yeah more people I asked more younger
people than I did older people it
doesn't matter cuz I talked to a
linguist from Columbia this is an Ivy
League school
where people know what they're talking
about and she's gonna settle the IMHO
debate once and for all right Michelle
absolutely in my humble opinion is more
like lots of love in my honest opinion
is more like laughing out loud eighty
years ago people would sign their
letters lol lots of love language
changes my mom always says to me lol
when I text her goodnight you're saying
you think in my honest opinion is
correct I'm not gonna say it's correct
it is far more commonly used by younger
people than my older people this is the
new and emergent and evolving way to say
IMHO but really what you want to say is
IMHO IMHO doesn't really mean in my
humble opinion or in my honest opinion
it means I'm going to tell you my
opinion whether or not it's appropriate
for me to do so or not but if I'm just
going to put my opinion out there
it's hedging your strong opinion it has
its own meaning everyone's wrong so the
honest in the home
matter not really why has there never
been a definitive decision though
merriam-webster and Oxford
they both say humble I would love to
know the average age of the
lexicographers in the world I would
guess it's probably over 25 I'm not
gonna say they're too old to really know
okay I'll say they're too old to really
know you can't trust them
who's the final arbiter of what is the
correct definition 100% of 18 to 21 year
olds have a cell phone with 100% of the
young people are communicating in this
language variety they're gonna win iMHO
is basically just going through puberty
it is definitely going through puberty
so that's the answer
I am H Oh means something beyond honest
or humble let's stop talking about it we
ended it it's over let us know you're
honest
no no cuz we just told them it's over
and don't let us know okay in the common
don't you dare comment on your opinion
on this video because whether it be
honest yeah it's over we don't want to
hear it weird we already figured it out
we figured it out you're welcome